John is making pasta dough to make the
dough he mixed three halves cups wheat
flour with 3/4 cups regular flour in
some water
write an inequality to express the
relationship between the wheat flour and
the regular flour so he mix three halves
cups of wheat flour three has is the
exact same thing as 1 and 1/2 if we were
to write it as a mixed number so it's
more than one cup of wheat flour and he
mixes that with 3/4 cups of regular
flour well 3/4 is less than one so three
halves is definitely greater than 3/4
and we can write that we can just pick
greater than right over there three
halves is greater than 3/4 let's do a
couple more of these one of the deepest
points in the Indian Ocean the D month
Deena trench is at negative 8 kilometers
we say it is negative 8 kilometers
because it is 8 kilometers below sea
level
the deepest part of the Bering Strait is
at negative 5 and 4/9 kilometers write
an inequality to show the relationship
between these two points and determine
which point is deeper so let's say we
have a greater than sign here so we want
to write whichever quantity is greater
on the left-hand side so we look right
over here this number 5 negative 5 and
4/9 it is less negative so it's actually
going to be a greater value it's not as
deep so we can write negative 5 and 4/9
is greater than negative 8 or negative 5
and 4/9 kilometers is greater than
negative 8 kilometers and so if we're
thinking about which point is deeper
it's going to be the one that's more
negative because that tells us how far
below sea level we are so the negative 8
kilometer point is further below sea
level and that is so let's see negative
8 kilometers the diamant
Tina trench DM DM montina trench a
negative 8 kilometers is the deeper
point and this is fun because in some of
these questions you actually learn
things I always thought the I always
thought that the deepest part of the
bearing
see well anyway we can we can talk about
that another time so at negative 8
kilometers so the de montina
trench deem diamantina trench is deeper
let's do one more
John is making noodles to make the
batter he mixes eleven sixteenths cups
tacky oppa tapioca flour with 3/8 cups
rice flour and some water write an
inequality to express the relationship
between the tapioca flour and rice flour
so we're really comparing 1116 cups of
tapioca at a 3/8 cups rice flour so
we're really comparing these two
fractions and at first it might seem
hard to compare you have different
denominators but 3/8 could easily be
converted to a fraction with 16 as a
denominator what would you do well if
you doubled both the 3 and the 8th you
have to do the same thing to the
numerator and the denominator this
fraction 3/8 is equivalent to 616 and
then you would have the same denominator
you could compare eleven sixteenths to
616 well if you have the same
denominator and this numerator is
greater 11 is greater than 6 11 16 is
going to be greater than greater than 6
16th which is the same thing as 3/8 and
we got it right